[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith [ __ ] we're all here ladies and
gentlemen what a [ __ ] amazing moment
to be here when we just got the worst
[ __ ] news in the world dropped on us
we'll get to that in a minute for right
now though we are at scum and villainy
the scum and villainy cantina on
Hollywood Boulevard in Hollywood
California put your hands together so
the folks watching at home know your
reel before we do anything I'll be
honest with you I must love this show
cuz coming here to do this show is about
the only thing that could torn me away
from watching the boys [ __ ] is that good
oh my god like two weeks in a row I like
you got watching [ __ ] boys I think I
got my wife on the hook man cuz I was
watching she's like what is this and I
was like it's a superhero thing is she's
going but they're hurting each other I'm
like yeah I thought you might like it
it's wonderfully [ __ ] made Kripke did
a great job [ __ ] writing it adapting
it the first episode was directed by a
guy named Dan Trachtenberg he had done
the 10 Cloverfield Lane yes the
Cloverfield movie but I know him as the
guy that got me into podcasting long
[ __ ] time ago we're doing like clerks
to him and a partner his they had a
podcast called geek drone and found me
on the internet I probably from our
message board cuz his pre Twitter and
said hey do you want to do a podcast and
I was like oh my god this is I've heard
this word you know cuz Scott Mosier came
in it was like hey man you want to
[ __ ] listen to the Ricky Gervais
podcast and I was like what is that and
he goes a podcast it's kind of like a
commentary track for a movie but there's
no [ __ ] movie and I was like well we
do that all the time but with a movie we
should make one of these podcast you
know and so we never pursued it i sat
down with dan and his partners what is
it
Thank You Josh Campbell
and they recorded an episode of geek
trolling with me and you got to see it
before he could be right so what I did
was see two kids and they were [ __ ]
pups they were real kids and [ __ ] come
in with like their little recording
device set up three mics and [ __ ] and we
just started talking and it was so
[ __ ] free and I was just like so what
we could talk about anything
I get like duh not to worry about
cursing like you do everyone and I was
like I [ __ ] love this you know so I
fell in love with it because that and
then you know said mojo I was like we
should record that podcast thing and
then we started Smaug kiss cuz I saw
somebody do it and how easy it was I had
to go get the little recording device it
was an mtech in the beginning so I'm
watching the boys and like [ __ ] love
and I'm [ __ ] this shit's shot like a
goddamn movie it looks fantastic
really [ __ ] visually sumptuous
composed incredibly well acting great
across the boards and at the end they
put up the credit and I was like that's
the [ __ ] who taught me in a
podcast man I was like and I've done
many podcasts and he went on to have a
real career maybe that was the plan all
along man he's like here shiny light
podcast then he went over and took a
[ __ ] movie career away and [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's talented I loved the first
episode the second episode was a wonder
I'm on for right now
[ __ ] oh oh my god so and it's gotten
to the place where Jennifer at one point
she was like hey which is her version of
let's [ __ ] in the afternoon but I was
like ah
this [ __ ] just took down a plane
[ __ ] off
spoilers [ __ ] loving it it's great
it's so great a programming if you
haven't seen it yet [ __ ] it's on
Amazon Prime
yeah and the guy who [ __ ] plays I
will ride hard for home Lander who is
this [ __ ] guy and he's like said he's
like the dark Chris Evans man or or
really the dark Chris Pine he's more
piney than anything else you have to
frosted tips and everything very much so
oh like on the [ __ ] on a dime he goes
from like hey guys everything's gonna be
fine they're all gonna die now yeah yeah
he's wonderful I'm telling it's not weak
the link in the cast Karl Urban is great
[ __ ] Jack Quaid's great who's the
girl who plays star Erin Moriarty I
think her name is fantastic oh my god so
good and locking Elizabeth Shue Thank
You Man cuz I was sitting there watching
it going jesus [ __ ] christ man she
like rocks and this i'm hoping to god
she joins Karate Kid Cobra Kai next cuz
spoilers at the end of season 2 spoilers
if you haven't seen season to cover your
[ __ ] ears we get five seconds [ __ ] it
three [ __ ] we're talking about now
there Johnny threw his [ __ ] phone and
then [ __ ] a notice came up where he
got a text from Ali who was played by
Elizabeth Shue movies so I was a wat the
fog random my wife I was like ah he's
coming back you know who the [ __ ] I was
talking about and [ __ ] but I was so
excited
sar on this show I was like she don't
need it man like she's [ __ ] runnin
[ __ ] in this show she's fantastic
excellent casting choice thank you for
shouting around
yeah man quality across the boards I
ain't getting any money and there's some
people accuse me of [ __ ] no all the
time all the time though you're in the
back for the [ __ ] I am in as much as
like I'm a [ __ ] fan and I like
well-made [ __ ] you never hear about [ __ ]
I don't like you'll hear about the [ __ ]
I like all the live long day speaking of
which I and I guess I had no dressing
because I saw a bunch of tweets gone
like man you only talk about the [ __ ]
you like and you didn't say [ __ ] about
Shazam
I loved Shazam we talked about you
talked about it you were there I thought
I [ __ ] [ __ ] you I talked about
chipping
goddammit man I do everything the
internet says I thought I did I was like
I don't get away of that when I went to
England I shut down a little bit not a
lot but a little bit as as my want but
yeah we're like I [ __ ] loved it oh my
god is your want it was so wonderful it
was everything I wanted to be and
[ __ ] Adam Brody showed up and I'm a
big Adam Brody fan so yeah
I've the [ __ ] people that made me
think I didn't talk about it which is
easy to do because I'm always based I
did talk about a [ __ ] you
I loved Shazam but anyway yeah I and in
the van get paid for anything [ __ ] I
just [ __ ] love it and I love the boys
they're doing a great [ __ ] job the
Lord's work so if you haven't seen it
check it out yeah wait til the end
you're gonna love the [ __ ] name did
you make it all the way oh yeah I mean I
honestly when this is done I'm going
right the [ __ ] back I'm not going to
sleep tonight [ __ ] sleep man I'm just
gonna sit there [ __ ] chain-smoke
Caviar's and watch that [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay so what do you been up to what I've
been up to how was your week dear you
know some wonderful things happen and
thank God we had that to talk about
otherwise we've [ __ ] crying right now
about [ __ ] Sony me and Mark over the
weekend announced that we're working on
a [ __ ] show man the good folks tell
television and Netflix are bringing back
Masters of the Universe as an original
anime series that's the thing we've been
talking about or hinting at for weeks on
the show it was so like remember the one
day we were people start shouting out
[ __ ] not a single person said masters
the universe and I was like thank
[ __ ] god somebody said something
about a couple weeks ago and we were
like I don't know you know so really a
student last week maybe two weeks ago we
talked about he-man for somebody
sometimes like if you could reboot like
he-man what would you do I don't know
put in better hands than ours yeah we
deferred we lied essentially and whatnot
and check the truth rely yes until we
were allowed to talk about it so it's a
big beautiful thing that you know we've
sat here for many a week and been like
why can't we get any of that [ __ ]
Netflix money man we finally got some of
that [ __ ]
Netflix money all right so so explain to
me because I'm not even sure that I
noticed part of it how did you get the
Netflix money when did they come to you
I'll be honest this was one of the
sweetest [ __ ] arrangements in my
professional career generally what
happens is people get you on board and
then they're like alright now we're
gonna go out and pitch this thing and
you're an element so we think it'll go
better with you because they're like
people know your movies but what they
don't know as I pitch all the time and
people like yeah I know your movies
there's the [ __ ] door so you know
just being me don't necessarily mean
anything and [ __ ] like that
so a phone call from my agent he's gone
folks at Mattel want to sit down with
you and I was like really like [ __ ]
please tell me for Barbie and they were
like close he-man I was a call [ __ ] Arzo
alright yeah if I can you know I was
like where is it and they were like it's
in Santa Monica it's got [ __ ] and
they said don't come to your house I was
a goal meetings on you know so Rob David
who is our producer and and the guy
who's really like kept MOTU alive for
years he wrote for those of us in the
world of comic books he wrote infinity
war for DC and whatnot he's Eternia
attorney I'm sorry [ __ ] infinity
where you write that one man it was like
I would thankfully write Infinity Ward
did Mark isn't McFeely Oh like who wrote
Infinity Ward he wrote it's the Eternity
war was the Eternity War saga is what it
was called my bet thank you well caught
he's the guy that's kind of kept MOTU
going for like the last eight years
attending I think he's I think it's been
eight or something like that so he came
over and showed me the books and whatnot
I was familiar with the comics comic
book story he was like where are you on
he-man I said I never really [ __ ]
through that as a toy that when I was
kid because my parents were like we're
done with toys like [ __ ] we bought
all that Star Wars [ __ ] and now you're
grown up like so no more than [ __ ] so my
friends collected he-man but I watched
it religiously so I knew it and stuff
like that so I was like oh I can go deep
on the mythology so they're not
obviously as hardcore as DC or marvel
but I'm well [ __ ] burst and [ __ ] we
talked about it like Jesus you're
well-versed so we started having this
conversation where they were like we
we've got a show already like at Netflix
Netflix is like we want to do this so
when they came to me that's already done
so they're like look there's gonna be a
show Masters Universe show had Netflix
with or without you so you know I was
like can I [ __ ] be in it you know and
they're like that's why we're here and
[ __ ] so we started having a conversation
and they were like what would you do and
I gave them a story and they're like we
[ __ ] like that man listen we're gonna
take it back to Netflix and see if they
like it at Netflix we have this amazing
exact Ted Bo celli who's just like the
biggest moat we call it masters the
universe is a big mouthful so we call it
mo - biggest mo to fan on the planet
he's the one who's responsible for
bringing it to Netflix he you know as he
says he's like look everyone's got their
thing he's like I love Batman I love
Marvel but like my number one thing was
always Masters of the Universe and stuff
so he spearheaded the project and
brought it in with with Rob they had a
conversation the show built from there
and then they were like let's find
somebody to do it they reached out to me
I was like I be yeah be into this here's
what I do
he took Rob took the pitch - Ted Ted dug
it we went and sat down at [ __ ]
Netflix and I've been to Netflix like
many many times with no [ __ ] luck
ever man they're always super happy to
see me and super [ __ ] polite I think
that's their training across the boards
and [ __ ] and you always get oh my god
I'm a huge fan and [ __ ] and like one
time I wanted to pitch Mallrats as a
series and so I sat down people like oh
my god mall rats is my religion I'm a
huge fan and I wasn't great then you're
gonna love this and I pitched him
they're like thank you and that was it
and I think you guys got Zen masks [ __ ]
man you know headed out so I'd go in
there all the [ __ ] time
and never found any purchasing [ __ ] this
was nice walking in knowing that like
the thing was in progress so I just had
to impress you know in order to get the
[ __ ] job so when and met with Ted
that was wonderful
he stands apart as an exact man he's
just so [ __ ] creative and he wants
like he wants this to be everything he
ever dreamed it could be when he sat
there and watched the show and collected
everything when he was a [ __ ] kid so
he's deeply [ __ ] invested so much so
when we sat around like breaking story
he joined us like which is I mean you
work in the world of TV how well that is
both weird and usually not welcome yeah
like I don't really want the executives
here like let's pitch them when we're
ready to do our razzle dazzle but like I
don't want you in the process but he was
additive and not subtractive like he was
and the biggest [ __ ] cheerleader yes
a huge pillar and like would drop like
fire legit fire ideas where you're like
holy [ __ ] that's [ __ ] tight and [ __ ]
and so like he was absolutely still is
welcome prosit say something for a while
my uh I think we talked a little bit
about when when we first signed on is
that where it's where you at on he met
mark and I said I remember it but I was
honestly I was more of a Thundercats kid
then I was a humanik it [ __ ] up we just
got jobs bad [ __ ] we just got some of
that Netflix money for a second that was
like I fought for the south and these
[ __ ] alive you even know just
like because I was in animation nut and
the animation in Thundercats
was a little bit better than the
animation in he-man and no
and I know that because we bought
themselves over the weekend and those
who listen it's glorious and lovely they
are painting on acetate like I don't
really impress her about that but uh but
of the dudes with swords that like grew
when you said some words I was a lion-o
guy
you remember that genre at the video
store
[Laughter]
horror fantasy dudes who grow with
swords you were just suddenly getting
used to things growing when you say the
words whoo oh my god you're right it's
like a narrative like an al analogy for
puberty totally never real under under
for a second there me and Mark we're
working on a kid show and I think we
just lost you haven't read my draft yet
that's right we're uh we're in a world
of a cycle where we can't I can't appear
'fl in terms of what we say we've been
instructed on a bunch of things that we
can't say and reveal and stuff like that
but I you know look at whatever they
release and go off of that and stuff so
they have said series they have so that
makes all right so that's they were even
kind of like we can't talk about how
many we can't talk about when we can't
talk about how big like they just want a
big but in the release they said it's a
serious okay so that means we've got a
few writers and we introduced them at
the panel we did if you haven't watched
that episode of fat man Beyond we threw
it up on the website Howard Kahn
which is a lovely convention Howard Kahn
is fantastic man they they've been gone
for seven years it's every comic book
show I remember from growing up perfect
size and stuff's not like San Diego
comic-con sprawling and ultimate hotel
yes and manageable and stuff and fun and
beautiful and God those cats are
they also Val runs the site heman org
which is for me been an invaluable site
like I go there for details constantly
where I'm like Oh even not only just
spellings and [ __ ] names and [ __ ] but
also like oh where will this this could
fit in the story and stuff they go deep
and long in their encyclopedia section
so we've been working on the show for a
couple months I think so yeah
and we introduced at the thing the
entire panel of writers and stuff me and
Mark are just two of them we want to
bring up the other three right now and
chitchat about it with you all so please
welcome up Eric dia and Tim man come on
up kids for the uninitiated Eric we've
had here before up here behind the bar
with us he was a fill-in meet I was the
Robin and the mark that's right man
but Eric I met on Supergirl he wrote for
Supergirl for how many seasons three
three what are the rest your bona fides
I did another Netflix cartoon legend
quest I did some Justice League cartoons
some of them with this guy and I did a
Justice League animated movie called
Justice League versus the fatal five
that came out a little fatal vibe is
yours
Tim you also worked on DC movies as well
yeah Eric and I met do another legend
quest show for Netflix and Justice
League action I did reign of the
Superman that was a movie that came out
this year right got a short movie out
right now called sergeant rock it's it's
on top of it's on top of that sound so
[ __ ] dirty it's on hush it's on the
DVD that still sounds dirty yes it does
what does that mean yeah I know what you
mean but explain that to me I've got
like so many NBA's with Warner Brothers
I cannot even confirm to you that Warner
Brothers is a working studio that means
you've got multiple stuff in the
pipeline which we'll hear about like
later on I know that I know but just for
these cats like they're being obscure
they like them over there so you
continue to work there you also they
like over there so you'll continue to
work there and you I've done jack [ __ ]
do you ever done one of those things but
you came from Magic the Gathering which
is a Netflix yeah that's a Russo
brothers series sure so yeah you came
from nothing what the [ __ ] man with
anyone here but I know this guy because
we have the same sort of like chaos
scammer energy at comic-con yeah I
explained that it means that if you
don't get your food for free you don't
deserve to eat so you go to comic-con
you eat for free that's familiar
you got a sneaking that's what we do I
want to get in on we sneak into all the
parties and we dance and we dance
through the thing oh we're supposed to
be here and then it's great and that's
how we met and that's actually how we
met as well but I just like conned
everyone into thinking that's how you
you got a job because you lied for
dinner once this town man [ __ ] I don't
know why I'm here
what is uh what it was did you are you
also on stuff that you can't talk about
have you done stuff you can like I mean
I don't think I can really talk about
magic and that was that was the thing I
was on my last day at magic and I got
email that was like signed this NDA
because Kevin Smith wants to talk to you
about a thing and I was like cool yeah I
was like tell me about magic she's like
I signed an NDA for that already my [ __ ]
and we got lucky that it was that it's a
Netflix sure it is because they were
able you're able to talk about it on
panel for this but otherwise you
probably wouldn't even say no I can't I
can't I can't tell you that there is a
magic show Netflix that is not a working
thing she can't confirm the NDA's the
but that was they they like Teddy knew
you you guys his work from you I can't I
can confirm Teddy is the exact on Magic
the Gathering I just came off working on
another Netflix animated series that I
don't they haven't announced me but they
announced the show so I think I can say
that I did work on transformers war for
Cybertron so that I finished that up and
then came to work for you so did you
meet had you met there you knew two
mothers gonna ask me like if I met
Megatron or so yeah I was like do you
[ __ ] know Megatron I've known Ted for
twenty years
go away yeah and when you set him up as
like the ultimate moto fan he has wanted
to make this show that we are making
since ever since I've known him and
certainly before that like since he was
12
you know he's wanted to make this show
so this is a big dream come true for him
for anybody that you know and there was
a lot honestly the reaction you know
whenever you nounce something you clench
your [ __ ] a little bit cuz just in
case people like alright hold on but
this time around everyone was like
[ __ ] nice this makes sense and what I
saw which was overwhelmingly beautiful
was are a bunch of people who react the
way I react when I [ __ ] watch like
how to Russo's handle Marvel material
where I get emotional and I get [ __ ]
like ecstatic just knowing there go do
something not just the bruises but
Marvel in general lets us say Kevin
foggy because I'm like oh my god they're
gonna [ __ ] crack my childhood open
again and stuff same thing I've been
seeing tweets when people were like you
understand I used to watch [ __ ]
he-man with my dad
I used to watch heman with my sister
[ __ ] like stories going on about
their deep connection to the material so
there's hope they're not like a series
of people going you know don't [ __ ] this
up although that's the undertone of
everything right on the surface man
they're just like we believe in you they
also hosers guys these are fans who have
been who've been deprived of
entertainment for so long I mean back on
and so the Amish then are the big fans
they had to give it up for rum Spriggans
you get to watch me man or you get to
join the natural world it is it's he's
the guy on board that if anybody cuz I
saw a few people being like because it's
because my name is attached
I saw a few cats put up tweets that were
like oh [ __ ] Cringer and Orko are
gonna sell weed outside of [ __ ] could
be in store they're gonna talk about
Star Wars that you like as if that's the
only thing I've ever done in my career
and stuff like it's gonna be sooner how
many Knicks team and they're like what
the [ __ ] he gonna do with fists oh you
know [ __ ] like that so I've seen a bunch
of that trust me even if I was just like
old why have an interesting use for
Fisto number one they'd be like it's
been done
number two they'd be like that ain't
gonna happen here like we are playing it
as close to the classic era as possible
and some people have asked online like I
don't get it that you guys talked about
we're picking up where the classic era
left off interests and [ __ ] how do you
do that when the show single episodes
and it did not have a mythology and
stuff but it did have a mythology it
just wasn't like you know punched in
your face constantly but it ran
throughout a bunch of episodes and
that's the stuff that we get to play
with when we sat down and started
breaking story it was all about that it
was all about taking these characters
and telling a story that was the next
chapter and the guy who had to approve
it is the world's biggest fan so we
couldn't just throw [ __ ] past him it
had to be legit because
you know he as you sit there listening
to him talk about it and throw in you
realize oh he does even need us he could
totally [ __ ] do this by himself but it
can't because he's got [ __ ] 96 other
shows like he should [ __ ] write this
like it's in his blood in his DNA and
stuff but he entrusted us to do it and
so when we handed in what we handed in
he like [ __ ] went for it and that to
me was like if you get him you get all
of family and like if he's the number
one fan like Rob David might be number
two number two and and rob has been
carrying this for Mattel is very
protective yes characters they wouldn't
let us [ __ ] with it nobody's like oh
it's [ __ ] keV it's not like I'm
[ __ ] Quentin Tarantino I'm sure if
Quentin Tarantino came in and it was
just like I want to [ __ ] with this
they'd be like go ahead put [ __ ]
Silent Bob don't walk in a room be like
I'm gonna [ __ ] with this they're like
get the [ __ ] out you know so I mean but
I wouldn't want to [ __ ] with it like
same way like I love when people
reverently treat the [ __ ] characters
that I grew up watching or engaging with
that's how I'm treating this like I'm
not going in there to be like look we
got to make it grown-up so everyone's
fucked-up and wrong and [ __ ] we're just
telling the next stories and more
importantly like this is what the folks
at powerhouse are amped about [ __ ] I
never really thought about what I would
I would appeal to me about those shows
always is there dialogue any man this is
about relationships people talking to
each other and [ __ ] and every once in a
while there's a [ __ ] fight but those
fights are pretty you know there's a lot
of hand they head roles and [ __ ] like
that and there's not a lot of hardcore
fighting what powerhouse animation wants
bring to it and what you know we the
dream for the show is when you were kid
and you watched it you were like you
know you had better fights with your
action figures than they ever did on the
show we're going to put like wicked
fighting into the show I feel like what
you imagined the show was when actually
sometimes wasn't that but it was the aim
is to look the show is more like the box
art or the figures like which always
looks so [ __ ] metal
what not and then you'd watch the
cartoon and you know they were like the
moral this story is don't [ __ ] up and
[ __ ] like that
so you know we're we're honoring what is
gone [ __ ] before in a big bad way
we're continuing it that's how we're
honoring it one night somebody I saw
somebody - based on our breakdown like
teal is in it and people were just like
oh [ __ ] this is an all teal a [ __ ]
thing isn't it
it's a he-man thing but Teela like if
Masters of the Universe is Star Wars
Teela is your central Princess Leia
figure she was in every [ __ ] episode
of the show she's essential she said she
always was she will be essential to this
also exactly and it's no different it's
nothing it's not like boy we got
something up our [ __ ] sleeves man
it's all of the characters and the title
I can't [ __ ] say like more without
getting in trouble but you got to just
think if you're a he-man fan or Masters
of the Universe fan think about our
title its masters universe revelations I
could say this because it was written
into the breakdown they used the term
about blah blah blah end of the universe
that was the original title for the
series was masters in the universe end
of the universe so like it's a pretty
[ __ ] like big epic story but then we
all decided revelations was kind of more
on point we're obviously not going to
end masters the universe you know times
is now like it's back now it's [ __ ]
dead nobody touch it for another 30
years No
so the title sounds angels come down
they're serious gwen stacy but we're
living on this thing like it like we got
a guy who's two guys over us who
wouldn't let us do like what some people
would say my version I'll be honest with
you I don't want to do my version I
don't want to do any [ __ ] version -
hey man where it's like people are
supposed to mean [ __ ] I would love this
to be just like [ __ ] he-man so that
nobody goes it's got to seem like
continuity of service I don't want
anybody like your [ __ ] he-man didn't
smell like he meant all smelled like
[ __ ]
all rats or something like that you've
never done this before no saying that
has never read your green arrow has
never read your daredevil you've done
that and to be fair but that shows you
like the comic-book community is much
smaller than than the mainstream
community and stuff so folks that know
my comp of work I don't think they're
the ones like bitching I think it's just
people who are like isn't that a [ __ ]
song Bob and to be honest and just to
make this clear not a lot of bitching
like it's not like I'm can't [ __ ]
deal with this the overwhelming
expression of support and love when we
announced this on the Internet right up
until the moment I walked in here has
been fantastic never be you you will be
cool you too will continue to be cool
but for us we sort of got there like
backwash people wanted pictures with the
writers they wanted autographs from I
was important I felt like we got to
bring everyone up show them the faces
man like this is the people that are
safeguarding your childhood number one
is good for me because I'm like them to
don't just [ __ ] blame me and [ __ ]
like that but number two it's like I you
know I don't know that's why I like to
bring in Teddy abroad was up there
because we were under the guise of it
was a robb panel and stuff like that but
I likes bringing Teddy up as well in the
powerhouse kids and you guys just so
everyone can see like this is real these
are the real faces behind it these are
human beings and stuff like that these
are the people that are gonna Shepherd
this thing in like just make it a little
bit more real people and give people
their proper I know how hard all these
people have worked on this man we sat
there for a long time and [ __ ] broke
story and sweated over coming up with
the right [ __ ] story to tell and
really feel like we arrived on it and
stuff so that had everything to do with
you guys so it was important to me like
let's bring them up too you know and I
was I was a kid I was like six seven
eight years old when he man was on first
round and so it was like you know he
meant transformers and Batman worked the
80s for me and I didn't know what to
expect when I came in that first day
with you
and I was I couldn't I couldn't believe
how steeped in masters the universe lore
you are now you're you know that [ __ ]
mute all that [ __ ] that people tell you
why you wasting your time watching that
[ __ ] you just have to prove him wrong
over a lifetime you know what I'm saying
like and I would catch so much [ __ ] from
my cool friends like why are you
watching that I'm like I'm because it's
good now it's fun I like to be got a lot
of characters reminds me of like DC and
[ __ ] like that and so you everything and
you love it and the manufacturer no use
had found a place some time late wasn't
then in the moment but later on down the
line I was like oh I I do know an
inordinate amount of [ __ ] about this and
the watchword as we went into our
writing session because like that's what
Rob and and Teddy we're talking about
was like these characters you got a
world of characters a toy box full of
characters treat and and you know we've
seen the stories and stuff like that all
I asked this came from Teddy he goes
just treat it Shakespearean and I was
like done and [ __ ] done man
and so that's what we're doing we're not
making it gritty and graphic and now
this one's a [ __ ] killer and [ __ ]
like that it's just everything's got
like an epic feeling stakes if you break
it down it's about a family at the end
of the day man this is we're going you
know without the [ __ ] dragons and and
and boobs we're going Game of Thrones
eat with it cuz that's kind of what it
is to a large to get some dragons and
boobs no no we don't need that man
that's the other guys I mean the thing
that I responded to coming in not as the
world's biggest tea man fan was again
that we could treat it like it's real
drama yes when you're writing it it
seems with people who want different
things it's human people in some case
beasts people who all like have wants
and needs and desires and here's
obstacles you can put in front of them
like not not that every story is the
same but you can impart this level of
just attention and care and and and just
thoughtfulness to this stuff that hasn't
been done before to both elevate it
beyond what some of the other stuff like
it is but also make it the version you
always kind of
it to be while still being what it is
but by being the version we get we now
get to make as grown-ups who know how
this works and remember what it was like
to be a kid playing with toys hmm it
looked like that to me as a kid it
looked like it was mature and adult and
grownup that was Ted's point Teddy said
like when I watched it it was real and I
took it back to Batman I'd watched you
know [ __ ] the Adam West or what we
now call Batman 66 as a kid and that was
not like campy I'm like they might get
eaten by this giant clam what the [ __ ]
somebody save them you know so I I knew
what he meant when he said that I'm like
yeah of course you didn't watch this
gone like goofy [ __ ] fun you were
like [ __ ] I hope he doesn't win
I hope they beat Skeletor and every week
like [ __ ] they did it so treat it like
that treat it with the level of like
severity cuz we you know when we say
drama you don't want people being like
oh man it's gonna be a [ __ ] cry fest
that's that's what they did they did
dramatic stories as well and stuff they
were dramatic morality tales but it's
you know there'll be some fight II
big-time fighty fighty in it but this is
about relationships across the boards
through a family through a dynasty and
stuff so I don't know it's it's it's
really good what else should we talk
about I saw on the internet people have
asked about Shira which is a show we all
absolutely love and and they're doing an
incredibly original take on it which is
[ __ ] fun and stuff obviously it's not
theirs as a like quasi futuristic take
whereas ours is also set in a quasi
future but married to the timeline of
the classic era so as of right now you
know certainly for our first season and
certainly not for their are they going
to a second or something like that
there have been there's no like we got a
land or our ship just like they've got
like seasons to build their show and
establish we're gonna do the thing we're
gonna do before anybody talks about how
do you Jam these two wonderful things
together or blah blah blah we just need
a title
sequence that is 5% of school as there
they do have a great time that song
Warriors [ __ ] their title song [ __ ]
sigh I think I wrote half my episode did
you say Fox is that a thing the kids say
like it so I'm done using rocks it's on
to Fox yeah yeah done and done
so there's gonna be so weird tonight
with my wife when I'm like [ __ ] Fox
[Laughter]
[Music]
and that's why we hired you as a writer
kind of quick thinking right there found
the dirtiest person in the business my
my DMS did kind of blow up from people
like hey I'd be awesome voicing this
character oh [ __ ] and I said I'm sure
you would be dead but no that's not what
we want for this show still though your
dad and Skeletor be amazing you could
work out a lot of issues Muse tried to
break some news at the panel Jason Mewes
is like I'm he man he did try to break
some news he tried to get a job story of
that [ __ ] life man how's a game lower
you're more of a stink work but yeah if
we can of course naturally I'd love to
get them in there but then again I don't
want somebody being like oh it's [ __ ] I
knew it so we'd an attorney unsure so I
might need him to like stay away so it
can be as as he-man is that right trying
to keep don't you [ __ ] are gonna get
us in trouble stop it man you as weak
man Internet Weed Man
so it's real now we might just like
he-man yeah I like somebody did me as
man-at-arms which I thought was kind of
cute like a animated Silent Bob version
with man adore name somebody did a
he-man in the style of the cartoon
somebody did a man in the clerk's pretty
focused yeah man
time but it's also gonna be a long time
before folks see it I just to break
things down and and again this is not to
tell you how many episodes but there are
episodes it's a series I've turned in
the script for the first episode dia
turns in the script Monday on Monday to
the next script that comes in is by mark
the next script that comes in for
Episode four is by Tim the next script
that comes in episode five is Eric and
then the rotation kind of begins again
so the writing process has definitely
begun casting seems to be a ways away
although they asked me to put together a
casting document to break down the
characters like who would you be looking
for for these voices not actors or
actresses but like explain Adam to us
explain Eman to us a brief breakdown so
they can go out and start the casting
process but then once we have all those
elements we and that's for as many
episodes as we're going to do we hand
that all over to powerhouse in Austin
our animators the folks that did
castlevania and they start their process
and their process of naturally is a lot
longer than our process and Brad broke
it down the other day to be like figure
what are these a minute a week or
something like that where you're like
wait a second if we're doing like 30
minutes or something like that it's like
yeah there's your [ __ ] man so bad for
writing anything now it doesn't it make
sure for you to do it I know it makes
you want to do like five page scripts so
that you can get through it faster but
they told us to to keep it tight like
our scripts our submission scripts are
no longer than I don't know if they've
announced how long it is you know what I
can't say [ __ ] but there's a strict
length to them like we can't go over
them even by half page which you know
would seem like not that big a deal or
luxury in the realm of writing
particularly when it's like you don't
have to build this [ __ ] in the real
world you're just going to draw it but
it's like we won't have time we've got
this much time to tell a story and
anything over that you've got to start
hacking out other things because you're
not taking in consideration all the
fight stuff which spreads and takes on
minutes of its own and so so it's a new
process for me because I've not done
like animated drama at the clerk's
cartoon was years ago and it was not
dramatic in the least thankfully these
cats here have worked in animation this
cat here has worked in writers rooms and
stuff because I'd never been in one of
those either and they made my first
experience real [ __ ] easy man it was
fantastic you guys did a great great job
that's why I was easy to bring everybody
up I'm like these are people that
[ __ ] built the show with me and stuff
so more when we can reveal it as we go
on I think we covered all the possible
talking points and maybe put anyone at
ease that's been and again there was
nothing but overwhelming support but for
anybody that any question marks left I
just wanted to make sure we hit
everything and whatnot like we're
treating this as if you were in charge
of it it's that simple if you love this
[ __ ] it's being treated as if you're
[ __ ] in charge so thank you to well
he's gonna be here the whole show thank
you to Eric Tim and dia give it up for
your writers on mo - that was just
lovely man when we did the announcement
at our con like the internet lit up and
has been very positive for the last two
days and I've been driving around like
feeling good not like full of myself but
I'm like [ __ ] hey man life's good like
the Jay and Silent Bob reboot tour is
selling incredibly well so much so that
we keep adding [ __ ] shows and stuff
the premiere is coming together nicely
everything in it everything in the
[ __ ] mo - announcement like not only
do we have a [ __ ] gig but also the
announcement went over well everything's
coming up millhouse as we like to say
and then but into every [ __ ] life a
little rain must fall I open up my
goddamn internets and [ __ ] click on
top news on Twitter as I'm want to do
and see spider-man up top yeah and I'm
like oh [ __ ] they're announcing the
title of spider-man 3 and instead they
announced
to the [ __ ] universe man I guess
we'll be in the news section we are
steadfastly in the news we're in the
news right now mr. Mark Martin takes the
time to go find the news for you man
however this news found us give it up
for mark he found the news mark tell us
this [ __ ] horrible news so so yeah
money seems to be the root of all evil
yes pretty good book if I remember Kevin
Feige will ah speaking of the good book
the Lord Himself Jesus on earth
Kevin [ __ ] foggy will no longer be
involved with spider-man what yeah
that's the [ __ ] news that's the
[ __ ] news because here's the deal
Sony which produces and finances the
spider-man movies had brought on Kevin
Feige and model two sort of consultant
producing was that he was the lead
creative producer on homecoming and far
from home which allowed them to bring
spider-man into the Marvel Universe
including civil war before his own movie
even came out with the pitch being
wisely look people like these Marvel
movies man put him in one of our [ __ ]
captain america movies and then he'll
probably open real well in his movie in
fact why don't you let us help tell that
story like we're pretty good at this
sort of thing like everybody gets some
shine everybody gets some love
Sony financed the movies and released
the movies Marvel was getting 5%
first-dollar gross which means it's not
after any of the [ __ ] writedowns not
after the real money look at real money
5% of everything these movies make they
also had they also had all of the
merchandising which is a very sweet plum
which is a very sweet play because if
you'll remember George Lucas when he
made Star Wars the deal of a [ __ ]
century 20th Century Fox was like hey
we're gonna take all the rights we're
gonna release it you're gonna be the
writer/director and George said hey do
you guys mind if I take like sequels and
toys and they were like who gives a [ __ ]
about sequels nobody makes those and
nobody's [ __ ] buying toys and then he
sells Lucasfilm for four billion dollars
because he realized that the next day
like couple decades later but but the
Empire that would become Lucas room was
built on
so I got to keep the rights to the
sequels and I sold how I got financed
Empire Strikes Back and Return of the
Jedi was on the back of all the toys he
self financed those movies yes like out
of his own [ __ ] he's an independent
filmmaker at the end of the day and [ __ ]
many used twentieth Century Fox to
distribute those movies but 20th Century
Fox had nothing to do with Empire
Strikes Back Return of the Jedi other
than be like III captain they just
simply put it out whatever you want to
do he had all the money to do it because
we bought all those toys when they put
him out right and so Disney getting the
merchandising rights it's not
insignificant because they have a bunch
of [ __ ] parks and you can't not buy
that [ __ ] when you come out of the park
you can't not buy that [ __ ] for your kid
in Walmart or k-mart or anything that
has a mark in any holiday that kids seem
to give a [ __ ] about they would have
made and probably did make more than
they might have just on the toys then
they would have made in theatrical
release but so what happened was Sony
said hey let's keep this business deal
going you keep your 5% on the
merchandise and we're gonna make more
movies and Disney said well we'd like to
reexamine this deal we would like to
co-financed these movies with you we
will pick up half of it of the [ __ ]
cost of making them and these movies are
expensive they're not cheap they made
him like 200 million for like a Spider
Man easy so we will pay for half of them
but we also want half of the box of his
revenues not the 5% we took before we
want half and probably also keep the
toys because who are we [ __ ] kidding
and Sony said no Sony said let's just do
what we had done and Disney said we
don't want to do that and so they broke
up probably a little acrimoniously
to the point where spider-man will not
appear in any more Marvel Cinematic
Universe movies [ __ ] the world man now
there's also been reports this may not
be finalized right I mean this could
very well be a negotiation tactic I
don't know if it would have become
public if it was but it could be a first
volley a big [ __ ] volley across the
bow and they could always change their
minds a year from now when Sony puts out
the first Kevin Feige less movie and it
doesn't do well or it's not what we need
it to be or it just stinks on ice and
they go back and say hey about that 50
I still want that yeah it's not over yet
and also to be fair Sony didn't make one
pretty fantastic spider-man movie with
no or minimal contact with Kevin Feige
which is into the spider-verse
it's not impossible to make a fantastic
spider-man movie yes and I don't think
that's the thing here I don't know if my
disappointment is oh man like Kevin
Feige he's not gonna do spider-man
although that's a big part of it my
bigger disappointment is I liked him
mixed up in the Marvel Universe
that's what's gonna [ __ ] go away
that's what like I'll miss and you know
some people are like oh you're just
rooting for one [ __ ] you know
corporate Death Star to beat another
corporate Death Star and I'm like yeah
look they're gonna play funny boardroom
games regardless and [ __ ] big business I
just want to [ __ ] benefit a little
bit I got a little skin in the game I
like these [ __ ] movies awful lot
perhaps an unsafe amount we'll see one
day you know what I'm saying I just like
him too much but like I loved what they
were doing that a great thing [ __ ]
going on and you know I I some people
were like Disney's being greedy and [ __ ]
I don't see it that way I see it as like
they did all the work they made those
movies earn a [ __ ] ton of dough they got
5% and the toys like they're coming back
to the table they're asking for like
something more man and they're not
saying like you keep paying the bill
they're saying like we'll split it 50/50
we'll split the profits 50/50 it's like
oh please do Disney's gonna buy Sony I
can't see that happening but you know
[ __ ] couldn't have seen the BI and Fox
either and [ __ ] like no honestly that be
amazing I do I know I shouldn't say
people get shitty online no like [ __ ]
as people losing jobs you piece of [ __ ]
just because you want [ __ ] spider-man
to suck Captain America's dick
[ __ ] you and I understand there are very
real-world [ __ ] into complications
and that come from like these mega
mergers and [ __ ] like that
so yeah I guess we don't want them to
buy [ __ ] Sony and Sony's not for sale
just like Greenland so
so the other day yeah I guess we'll find
out but at the end of the day yeah I
guess I'm just like it's a first world
problem bitching about how man like
[ __ ] now I can't put all my toys in
one [ __ ] collector case and [ __ ]
goddamnit but you know whatever I'm sure
that something will be figured out and
the one like [ __ ] silver lining on
the dark cloud is Lord and Miller yes
who have a deal at Sony and could out
like if you have to bring in somebody to
make sure that spider-man does with
spider-man it's supposed to do the
Weibull spider-man is supposed to do it
the guys in the lego movie and the guys
that well did spider-verse as well yeah
you could do a lot worse you know and I
think that Sony believes that they they
have Tom Holland who now knows how to
play spider-man after having learned at
the feet of the master John why would
he's never gonna [ __ ] reference Tony
Stark again and [ __ ] like the whole
[ __ ] arc of that kid is that [ __ ]
love new mr. stark
and now [ __ ] what the next movies
gonna be like oh [ __ ] I remember I used
to have an uncle man you know Uncle Tony
I saw a bunch of [ __ ] people on
Twitter like you know when I saw this I
was like what the [ __ ] one of the
hashtags was Uncle Ben and I was like
did Sony announced already like the next
movies Uncle Ben but it was just people
on Twitter being brilliant like that's
you know I know twitter has done weird
things and I said all about it
I love the fact that twitter has
introduced us to a nation of really
funny people a lot of them funnier than
[ __ ] million [ __ ] so I go there to
hashtag and it's a bunch of people
putting up [ __ ] means you know that
one Jordan Peele sweating bullets bang
so they put up that gif and and it says
Uncle Ben when they hear there's another
reboot coming everyone making variations
of that joke Uncle Ben was trending cuz
so many people like what the [ __ ] now
they're gonna bring back home go Ben
again some person wrote I will I refuse
to watch Uncle Ben die for a fourth time
in my lifetime
[Laughter]
are we sure that it wasn't just a lot of
people who liked rice yeah I [ __ ]
tosser I put my own gif of Denzel
Washington [ __ ] being relieved when I
found out was just about rice
yeah man [ __ ] it's I don't know I wish I
can't [ __ ] rich people get along mark
money changes everything and it's not
even like these are like [ __ ] people
like who's in charge over at Sony Tom
Rothman and somebody been segata you
guys how she's a producer on spider-man
I'm sure she's the one right now going
[ __ ] give him all the money because
she knows that liable just patella bog
is yeah all right but Tom Rothman yes
he's in charge of Sony yeah of the
studio not of like Sony the corporation
correct
why is he get to [ __ ] make the
decision you know what I'm saying like
I'm not saying I should make the
decision but likes put it to a vote
Hunger Games that [ __ ] yeah yeah I don't
know it just seems weird I'm not gonna
turn I got in for a dudes job but it's
like we all want a thing mm-hm
doesn't he want that thing and what's
why wouldn't he want that thing cuz then
somebody be like you're fired for giving
away the house or something I don't give
a [ __ ] he'd be a legend in my book man
he could always come more good view
askew I'll tell you that right now man
III will I will say this that if you had
to put like faces on those two
characters there's a world in which Tom
Rothman is Lando Calrissian and [ __ ]
Disney's Darth Vader and Lando Slyke
this deal is getting worse all the time
like we had an agreement it's like well
I decided to re-examine this Agreement
his deal is getting worse all the time
but we had a deal at 5% they altered the
terms of the d-brane I don't altered
anymore well that's a good prism accrue
man [ __ ] they should put you to work on
Middle East peace negotiations you just
whip out the land bomb with all you
peoples you've never thought about which
one of you is Lando what's a colt 45
we'll fix this in a juice
alright well [ __ ] man these are I know
these are first world problems but
they're the first world he is the first
world problems but it really does bug me
I got no skin in the game I thought
about buying some Sony stock so I could
[ __ ] sell it today and if you want to
know how greedy these [ __ ] are
all of them combined they re releasing
far from home into theatres with like a
new scene even though even while this
fights going on I hate UI it's like
[ __ ] goodbye sex we're breaking up
let's [ __ ] one more time one last time
they put a movie out with a new scene
yeah what is it is the one they showed
us in the trailer of him beating the
pollutes up and the cops talking to him
it's an action scene they didn't
describe what if I can guarantee it's
that cuz we saw it in the trailer and
they didn't have it in the movie and
[ __ ]
Yeah right I'll look I'll [ __ ] go
back and stuff because this may be the
last time we get to see spider-man
touched by the hands of God
I'm a big Kevin Feige fan man like I'd
like he's I love the story he's telling
I don't want a job
please don't accuse me of [ __ ] like
want a job I could never make a Marvel
movie looks like a lot of work and I'm
not that guy but I appreciate when
something's done incredibly [ __ ] well
and I liked his handling of Peter Parker
and spider-man be honest with you is my
favorite not just cinematic iteration
but media iteration of them outside of
[ __ ] comic books you know and and of
course I include spider-verse which I
really [ __ ] love but god damn it man
Tom Holland Kevin Feige came up with
something really special with that
iteration the character I want the girl
with that [ __ ] man like you know I was
already looking forward to going back to
high school with him until the end of
the last movie like [ __ ] you his life's
ruined that was like now can't wait to
see it you know so now who knows what
they're gonna [ __ ] do well the upshot
is Tom Holland will never grow old I
know never die he's immortal do you what
he's a pain he must be [ __ ] torn
right I'm sure I'm sure
but you know it's can can somebody put
the analogy it's like trying to win the
chairmanship without Michael Jordan and
it's like is that hard
I don't know basketball you are familiar
with that there was a person named
Michael Jordan he's a shoe salesman if I
remember correct he was yes it looks
really good an underwear bit of a
gambling problem believe I saw him in a
Looney Toons but I guess that is a
pretty strong analogy yeah so like who
knows maybe it'll work on the image and
Oilers want a cup without Gretzky so
it's [ __ ] possible it's possible see
that's the problem I didn't make it
white I know
oh my god that was beautiful
all right [ __ ] enough of that bad
news man you got any good news
I don't know if it's good or not but you
remember they made matrix movies right I
do I remember one really amazing Matrix
movie yeah and then there were more what
another word yeah no no no no no [ __ ]
ended when he took up into the sky and
that was that
so they're making a matrix 2 now ha ha
[ __ ] really I'm into that yes I saw this
so if this came out of [ __ ] nowhere
it really did like there had been talk
that Warner Brothers was looking to
exploit the matrix universe I heard they
were making a with shouse Keys less yeah
matrix it was part of the writing
process and there was the rumor that it
was they were lying like Michael B
Jordan to be the lead it was gonna like
a young Morpheus stories which I still
really want but uh but no instead we got
the [ __ ] band getting back together
- one person No uh well I don't know
about Fishburne I haven't announced him
yet Keanu is coming back carry and moss
is coming back and lana wachowski is
coming back there's no mention
whatsoever of lily wachowski oh is that
right yes so I mean one of those shower
seasons is coming back we're not the
other yes Lana is gonna write in direct
and produce there was no mention in the
press that aside from acknowledging that
Lily co-wrote and co-directed the first
three grow but she does not seem to want
or they don't want her involved with
this fourth iteration oh yeah
and I don't know what the story is but
is it that was the one thing that was
curious like [ __ ] alright there is a
missing element but at least it's uh
Wachowski it is a wachowski at the helm
connected to the material they created
in the first right so yeah that is
happening I think what are they shooting
are you happy about this I'm like I'm
for it I'm not again it's again again
I'm not even indifferent I think I'm for
it I'm not like oh my god this is what
I've been waiting for I had no idea it
was coming and stuff but the key honest
aunts continues and it seems like he
wants to see equalize everything he ever
did yeah and this is one of those movies
I can get behind I hopefully he does it
for Point Break and I hope he goes back
to either even deeper and does [ __ ]
Youngblood that's what I'm looking for
Wow he played a [ __ ] Quebec
goaltender deep cut yeah man you could
play it like a coach this time I write
my own Private Idaho yeah but we're
missing the other guys that'd be tough
yeah but you still like very that's what
made me happy is that Keanu seems to be
enjoying himself to the point where he's
like well let's do another matrix and
like he wouldn't come back unless it was
gonna be good confidence sir back flying
in no it's heaven calling what's going
on JC with you pay the bills
[ __ ] blinking lights so it's the
matrix this is neo go and stop talking
about it
I thought if I remember the end like
didn't he give himself over like Jesus
to make peace between the machines and
the old lady and the old man and [ __ ]
yeah yeah no it was a very subtly
disguised Alistair what so this means
that the piece didn't last somebody kill
this [ __ ] dog is what it means oh
he's back all right well that's huge
[ __ ] news man
I'm sure they were like [ __ ] we dropped
that news on the day that [ __ ] Sony
and Disney had a big fight yeah we
thought we had this I know that is like
we're gonna on the internet wait till
they hear about this [ __ ] who did what
now
fine can we take it back yeah can we
wait till tomorrow well it's still that
is big news I'm sure they're gonna make
lots of monies east oh they will
I'll see it's not like I'm not gonna see
it yeah but who knew who didn't know
that was coming now I do I'm into it
speaking of old dudes coming back to a
franchise yeah
obi-wan Kenobi yes I am so
[ __ ] happy maybe when we talked about
it was supposed to be a movie when back
before solo came out and and Lucasfilm
was like no more of these there was
supposed to be standalone it was a
standalone Boba Fett movie that the
James Mangold yeah I was gonna do an
r-rated version and and Steven Daldry
from Billy Elliot was gonna do sort of
old man obi-wan Kenobi
all right middle-aged man obi-wan Kenobi
you've seen old man obi-wan but that has
more cancer I can do the show with Alec
Guinness as hard as they try no he'd be
very costly and people would be like
that looks gross it's so but so Disney
Plus has stepped in it was like well
[ __ ] it if we can get you and Mac let's
make a let's make a 49 year old obi-wan
Kenobi I figured out this Disney Plus
[ __ ] this is how we get to [ __ ]
sailing deck chairs and wall-e all those
[ __ ] in wall-e
just sat around watching shows and [ __ ]
that's what Disney Plus is gonna be like
every time you like maybe I should
[ __ ] go hike Runyon they're like you
and McGregor is obi-wan Kenobi and
you're like I can wait and then you'll
start drinking cupcakes through a
[ __ ] straw and she's like I could
chew this food or could you unbelievable
man [ __ ] another one this is like god
dammit they really want to destroy
[ __ ] every other streamer out there
don't they they just want to [ __ ]
make up for all the lost time in the
world like Netflix has how many
subscriptions I don't even know all of
them all of the subscriptions that it's
gonna take Disney they say originally
they were like it'll take them [ __ ]
years to catch up they keep doing [ __ ]
like this where the like hey remember
your childhood here it is give us 14
bucks we're all gonna [ __ ] pay
through the nose next program they're
gonna announce is we have your parents
if you ever want to see them alive by
Disney Plus and I'll be like smack here
it is are we gonna pay they're treating
them well so alright [ __ ] I'm on board
for that man you owe McGregor how great
that he'll get to go back to the role
totally I mean
Clone Wars
um I don't think so because that stuff
is still in Canon so I do you bring back
what's his [ __ ] no you know what's his
[ __ ] and Anakin Skywalker himself Jake
Richardson do you Brokeback Hayden
Christensen don't say no right away
let's think about it first do you bring
back Hayden Christensen I say yes cuz
then you could do some of that [ __ ]
this [ __ ] they did in the animated
series do they bring in a sokka's this
how they bring in ahsoka into the Star
Wars universe yeah I think they would do
that before they did David and
Christensen oh my god can it be rosario
Dawson please are you in charge yes then
make it right
Dawson will do oh my god and I also
think it's you could do young Luke yeah
we saw young Luke it was called [ __ ]
Star Wars man what do you want more net
for I say you do you could do you know
Obi Wan Kenobi cuz Alec Guinness can't
do it himself plus Ewan McGregor Plato
leaked obi-wan Kenobi going forward if
you were gonna do some more series man
you do [ __ ] like Boba Fett but they're
doing the Mandalorian so that kind of
cancels that out a little bit
honeydew [ __ ] with like the people that
like the cocoon cast they'll never get
older and they'll never die do the
droids you know [ __ ] give me a grito
series and [ __ ] anybody under [ __ ]
plastic so that it can keep going
forever and ever
this obi-wan Kenobi show you think it'll
have the droids in it it gotta be right
cuz he's like I don't remember owning a
droid and then but he did on that
[ __ ] droid as we saw in these other
movies but at the time he belongs to a
[ __ ] Bail Organa but at the end or
during those whole movies
well the this phase of obi-wan Kenobi
would presumably be the Obi Wan that is
safeguarding Luke on Tatooine so so no
droids unless he's got its own [ __ ]
choice I don't know if would be those
droids I'm out no I'm still in but
[ __ ] that's just a nice little
worrisome I mean cuz the version that
that I love the idea that I love is lone
wolf and cub with [ __ ] obi-wan Kenobi
living on Tatooine trying to get this
baby
you know [ __ ] uncle Owen and aunt Beru
and the Empire still on his [ __ ] tail
because he's got this goddamn baby I
like your story I want to watch your
story is that just one you made up
yourself yeah [ __ ] do that man like
you got me all excited for a show I'm
probably not gonna see that's a good
idea right there [ __ ] that'd be good
storyline alright done it for them
that's it for them I'm good I approve of
that I want to watch that show excellent
this is relevant to my interests I found
this interesting Marvel is in the
podcast business oh yeah with Wolverine
Wolverine they are all Lord winning
podcast yeah that's very good they
actually do is like tell a story and
stuff yeah gambits is in season 2
richard armitage is uh plays Logan but
they are now doing a Marvel's podcast
based on the Kurt Busiek oh that's a
good idea since bill as the voice so
Phil Sheldon is you sort of like using
the photographer and the Marvel if for
those who and everybody who doesn't
remember it Marvel's is this beautiful
book predated kingdom come well he's
frosted all the painting and it was told
through the perspective of a
photographer who worked at the Daily
Bugle and other races and he watched the
Marvel Universe come to life with Alex
Ross's gorgeous [ __ ] paintings and
stuff great book and the idea that doing
it as the park is is smart yeah because
you can do like the ground level view of
here's one regular human dude who's
witness to the creation of Human Torch
and the creation and the introduction of
many more and the rise of the Fantastic
Four in the beginning of the mutants and
Galactus shows up and all that [ __ ] but
just tell those as discreet episodes in
this guy's life he's kind of fascinating
he's very he was like Forrest Gump II he
was there for the entire Marvel Universe
very much that's a good idea
my favorite part of it is that Ben Urich
is a character oh [ __ ] yeah from
daredevil Method Man is voicing [ __ ]
Ben Urich
really yes he's deep into comics he goes
oh yeah he's true fan not just
carpetbagger he go hi
that's good call that's a regular call
that's good actor to man we haven't been
Jay and Silent Bob reboot and
[ __ ] on one take wonder like really
first [ __ ] take that most of the
performance him and red is in one
[ __ ] first the first take we shot I
was way impressed it was a croc and
thanks man
like we had six things to do that day
and so we had three hours allotted for
that and it was dead center in the
middle of like six other [ __ ] scenes
that we were doing all throughout the
day so like I was all over the place and
I never worked with them so I was like
now how long it's gonna [ __ ] take to
tell him how we do dialogue or work
through this or blah blah blah and the
first [ __ ] take they were just like
magic I could have cut and did cut 98%
of everything from the first take he's
one piece of the second take and mostly
because I felt bad that I had them do a
second take at all but you know I told
him at the first take I was like we
could literally be done now and they're
like we came all the way let's do it one
more time and so we did one more time
he's that [ __ ] good really good so
that's a good role I don't mean to brag
but I also did my role in Jennings
having Bob reboot in one take it's true
he did I mean [ __ ] around like you need
to not say anything really well I got
you yes marks like the Dormouse in Alice
in Wonderland he sleeps and then comes
alive and then sleeps again alright
that's it for him that's it for that a
bit of sad news Oh
our friend of the show Cameron cuff who
was on here a couple weeks nobody died
no a show died yeah show Dad camera cuff
came on that's a nice boy he was
standing right there and he told us all
about Krypton and yes and like made it a
show that I would watch literally sold
it better than anybody's ever sold
Krypton before yeah like sci-fi should
just like put him in front of the
[ __ ] pillar and just tell the story
and make that your commercial or make
him that of marketing or that too but
sadly was too little too late because
sci-fi cancelled Krypton bummer bummer
and also with it went the hopes for a
Lobo spin-off Oh
Lobo one oh why did you say no show bow
for Lobo Gonzalez [ __ ] man yeah and like
sci-fi is in the way
place where they don't produce a ton of
their own shows like it's they're always
beholden to Warner Brothers was Krypton
Sony was deadly class a lot of their
other shows or acquisitions from
overseas like killjoys came from from
Canada I think a couple of other shows
that as well and so when it gets too
expensive for those producers those
studios to make the show and sorry I
can't make enough money on it for there
and they just start canceling [ __ ]
because they don't own anything they
don't have that vested interest and so
sadly it results in you watching the
show that you love for a while and then
it just goes away I mean there's hope in
the same way like the expanse was in
that same boat and the expense got
canceled by sci-fi but it turns out that
Jeff Bezos his kid really liked the
expanse and literally that's what
happened that's how it God says how it
got saved why can't Jeff Bezos kid love
Jay and Silent Bob [ __ ] that's a longer
con I guess so and so yeah Amazon picked
up season four I want to say of the
expanse mmm
so these they're hope yeah I mean
[ __ ] I'm maybe Jeff Bezos the kid
really loves [ __ ] Krypton or any of
the other [ __ ] streamers might was
that a burl ante show um no that was
David Goyer but was it a burl ante
Perdue show at all no so that means
there's no chance that maybe he shows up
and like the big crossover and stuff
like that there's never no chance that'd
be nice it would be nice I'm too tight
speaking of crossover this is like
apropos of nothing but I got a text from
Marc Tyler nobleman hmm you know that is
he did the great Bill Finger doc yeah
it's on Hulu and wrote the book I am
bill I think it's called about Bill
Finger he's the guy who pushed that
forward like the bill finger as
co-creator of Batman for years it was
just Bob Kane and Bill Finger didn't get
the credit he deserved mark pushed for
it and stuff now Bill Finger at the
front of all the DC movies the Batman
they acknowledged that Batman created by
Bob Kane and co-created by bill figures
so mark always doing the Lord's work and
he's been on the show
he sent me this text and he said hope
you're well my friend you look great I
just tweeted you and Mark G and Greg B
oh I thought mark G were you it was you
know Marc Guggenheim yes is who he means
Marc Guggenheim and Greg Berlanti about
possible multiverse recruits for the
arrowverse crisis because you know
they're bringing people in like Kevin
Conroy is gonna play Bruce Wayne Burt
Ward we did they haven't said who he's
gonna play but you might [ __ ] play
Robin which would be amazing and stuff
so they're bringing people in for this
version this crossover this crisis not
just from a CW universe but from all
iterations of comics there's been rumors
about like will the Smallville universe
kind of show up and stuff like that so
Mark said he had some suggestions to
pass on to people in power and stuff no
see don't you work with Guggenheim once
upon a time on Colonel 400 that's all
done that's wrapped you can text him I
will this is the suggestions this is
this judges mark said for the crisis
crossover okay
the first live-action flash from the
original legends of the superheroes
which was the 1979 superhero roasts the
one that had Adam West the guy who
played flash he's still with us and he's
saying put him in the [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
not gonna text that come on man he was
your childhood flash so harsh the Wonder
Twins voice actors the kids who played
the Wonder Twins who have never reunited
on-screen never seen him on screen
together they can put them into Jan and
Zayn outfits and let him get killed by
some but form of residual check
still saucy and marks and marks final
suggestion and of course the pimp from
Superman the movie the van I will make
that [ __ ] text some time in the Sun
Yellow Sun I've interviewed them also
have contact information don't know if
Marc Guggenheim and greg berlanti
regularly read tweets so hoping you
could pass along the suggestions look at
zan and jayna come on man you want to
see them on the big screen don't you a
little TV screen totally not as much as
I want to see the pimp you can think you
do that line again that would be the
only reason you get them BBC's [ __ ]
Brandon Ralph in the in the Kingdom Come
Superman outfit other he's got to find a
phone booth for that [ __ ] because
otherwise you just standing on a street
shouting the people in clothes mark
doing the Lord's work [ __ ] not mark
Bernardo or not a nobleman doing the
Lord's work so how do we have them to
think about those cats this is not my
well it might be my favorite story of
the week
so remember why the last man right they
shot the pilot and and effects are still
pretty excited about it even though they
changed the the leadership on I what do
you mean oh because they purchased by
Disney yeah no not even so much as that
but they had let the showrunners go and
they brought in a new showrunner and
there's a whole new staff kind of oh why
it's done why the lasso but in the book
there Yorick Brennan has a monkey a
capuchin monkey yeah named ampersand so
anybody have a black sharpie
we just have silvers and thank you keep
telling your story sorry and so the
monkey is of course in the [ __ ] pilot
and it turns out the same monkey this in
the pilot was Ross's
monkey from friends no [ __ ] it is the
same [ __ ] monkey monkeys yes they
live that long say [ __ ] monkey Katie
yeah they live to be like 40 45 years
old holy [ __ ] a monkey and and I'm
imagining and I was talking with Tim
about this on the right up from power
con that like Katie is this saucy
[ __ ] like French monkey that is like
you [ __ ] want to get another
goddamn monkey in this [ __ ] [ __ ] you
nobody else it's our [ __ ] show that
like I do [ __ ] yeah I'm the prettiest
King Kong you've ever [ __ ] seen that
is my impression do you have other
character [ __ ] you're gonna work out
tonight we'll see when we get to the Q&A
it was adorable wait a sec it wasn't
there it was another oh is this the same
monkey that was in purge the Caribbean I
think it was a different monkey but it's
also the outbreak monkey what this
monkey hire is that [ __ ] monkey stop
it from getting a wild and spreading the
disease
I loved outbreak one of my favorite
[ __ ] movies man Dustin Hoffman his
action hero them he is he is we got to
stop that there's a great moment in that
movie where Donald Sutherland like
Dustin Hoffman is like you know we did
it in one episode of the clerks cartoon
Dustin Hoffman is like you know talking
to the pilot the pilots coming in with a
[ __ ] bomb and [ __ ] gonna blow this
town up and [ __ ] and he's like I'm
talking to the pilots and the bomber
please you have to turn around [ __ ] and
he starts giving them information too
much information and toweled suddenly as
the general or whatever he goes Jesus
Billy what are you dumb or something he
just told them what and then he realized
what he was [ __ ] doing and [ __ ] but
his what do you dumb or something is one
of my favorite deliveries of any line in
every any movie of all time Donald
Sutherland sold that [ __ ] light Jesus
Billy what do you dumb or something
anyway is that all the news that is all
the Newmark reg in the news give it up
[Applause]
Jamie you here where's those bags that I
snuck backstage during the well thank
you a couple weeks ago I will [ __ ]
months ago at this point we went to me
and J to the Disney lot and met goose
the Fleur Caen yeah
from Captain Marvel took pictures with
goose shot some video with goose that we
put up online and stuff when we left
they gave us a gift bag full of stuff
since they Muse had one too
this is mostly kid stuff from Captain
Marvel muses that gave his stuff to his
4 year old that was the only four year
old I knew except for the adult four
year old Jamie caddy oars herself so she
asked for it so just to showcase it
there's a gorgeous Captain Marvel and
Marvel's Goose figure there and it's
like a Barbie style style from as bro
and then there is of course what
everybody wants and needs a Sam Jackson
action figure Nick Fury action figure
himself obviously you know you don't put
the two together bless it's a weird
oversized adventure and stuff and then
finally this may be the coolest of the
swag they gave out they gave out a copy
of the movie of course I kept that [ __ ]
you but this is a proton photon Power FX
glove so you put on the glove and it
makes it so you can blast [ __ ]
across the room and so I was talking
about it and Jamie was like can I have
that [ __ ] and I sort of go my god so
Jamie it's yours it took me a few weeks
to remember but here come get your [ __ ]
man but the good folks at Disney and
you're wearing a Captain Marvel jacket
how perfect
what's this is named for my kid oh my
god thank you I didn't know we were
doing swaps
yeah Yankee Swap how to brought you
something alright man we've done the
news yes now we get everyone's favorite
part of the show this is the Q&A portion
of the show they want to talk to a dude
first [ __ ] yeah you're absolutely right
I forgot I'm so stoned I forget we have
a huge [ __ ] guest I got so deep in up
the ass of Castle Grayskull and up
Sony's ass about this thing that I
forgot we have a massive [ __ ] guest
in the house ladies and gentlemen all of
us have seen and engaged with Star Wars
naturally that attested to the fact that
force awakens made what [ __ ] 2
billion or something $1 which means
you're familiar with our next guests or
our first guests our only guest tonight
his work man
if you love bb-8 then you love bb-8 baby
daddy this is brian who created what's
created or control puppeteers controls
bb-8 and all the [ __ ] movies bang
hello Brian and I met when I went over
to England to visit a movie set which
we're not at liberty to say what the
first time we met was when you went to
the force awakens that's right then we
can talk about yeah just turned up and
you were crying your eyes out because
you just been shot the [ __ ] up man like
yes I did I was crazy are you British I
am did he kidnap you by accident kind of
reverse like on the side of a road and
invite you back to his house and like
offer you drinks and like weed and [ __ ]
because he seems to do that a lot to
British dudes he runs into how good
happened last week I know just point to
the doll where he touched you we met
long before that we met as Brian was
saying after a while I was visiting for
force awakens and they let me go see the
stage em where the Falcon was and stuff
and then I came back and I was watching
JJ she knows right before I went I was
watching JJ student seen him before they
were rolling I was sitting there talking
to Brian and I didn't know [ __ ] about
[ __ ] right like there's no now we all
know what the force awakens is at that
point it was like [ __ ] new to me I
was just shell-shocked at seeing
stormtroopers there's [ __ ] c-3po
there's [ __ ] Chewie
there's LAN solo and [ __ ] this was the
maz's castle scene when they blow it up
a winner
so we're in England so everyone's got a
British accent except some people and
stuff so Brian sitting me on the Honda
monitors and whatnot
it was like wow and I say man how are
you I said what do you what do you do
here and stuff he's like uh I worked
this little guy here and I was like with
the [ __ ] soccer ball
what is that and he started making a
move I was like get the [ __ ] out of here
what is this man and so that's how I met
Bibi a year you know months before
probably a full year before the [ __ ]
movie came out and months before the
trailer happened so in the trailer job
people like what that [ __ ] was with that
little Rolly droid and [ __ ] I was so
already in the bag with the Rolly droid
because I was like I seen it work and
Paul in person it's [ __ ] weird man
weird and [ __ ] wonderful you've been
running bb-8 since the beginning but
you've done a lot of puppetry [ __ ]
correct yeah tell him give him your bona
fides um I started on a TV show called
spitting image which is a Hass be show
back in he started in the 80s but I
joined it in the 90s and then from there
I worked for the Jim Henson Company in
the UK for about ten years started doing
some movies Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy Hellboy 2 what did you do on
hitchhikers I was the little Vogons that
were running around the minions and a
lot of the Vogon hands because my wrists
were quite thin so I could get into the
hands for the gloves and I'm also the
ravenous bugblatter beast of troll wench
they're lowering resume additionnal into
the cage you see this eyeball which is
my mouth with an eyeball in it and the
lips are prosthetic so I just they just
shot as a plate and put it in [ __ ]
hell all right what else I did
Prometheus for Ridley Scott and that's
how I met Neal Scanlan who is the head
of the creature department and he
brought me on board for the force
awakens as a publisher consultant
what were you doing on on the Ridley
Scott move those little think those kind
of snake things you know that those
hammer Pete things which you should
never go and just hope one of those
things because it's not gonna be that's
a good idea isn't just give that a poke
so we were doing those there was a
practical version other thing that came
out of her stomach and the the alien at
the end was also a practical effect
there were five puppeteers around that
and all that kind of stuff yeah
so then after force awakens they have
you been pretty much in the BBA pretty
much in that yeah pretty much in sort of
Star Wars course I wrote one and solo as
well that's [ __ ] right man holy [ __ ]
so what is the now when we think of
movies nowadays of course we think about
like you know everything's CG and [ __ ]
like that but puppetry is not it's not
it's live-action it you work in a thing
that exists in the real world and maybe
they digitally erase a stick here or
whatever the [ __ ] but it's it's a like
in almost a lost art form yeah I mean JJ
wanted to make a secret of the Return of
the Jedi like it was 1985 so he wanted
guys in rubber suits and practical
effects and it was very important to him
for bb-8 to be there as an actual thing
that the actors could interact with so
extremely clever people started trying
to work out how to do that as a guy
called josh and a guy called matt denton
and they worked out that they could make
this thing work and they created a
puppet version of it which has got Rod's
it's like a kind of a lawn roller so
they got myself and another puppet
tickle dave chapman and we kind of
worked out his personality and then when
have you seen it the behind the scenes
stuff i'm the guy in the green suit
running around through the desert and
then they just digitally removed me
afterwards here they like put this on
puppeteer yeah exactly push them put on
some it really hot and go out somewhere
really really warm and run everywhere
through sand so there's lots of
different versions of it as well there's
there's versions with wheels on the back
that drive around like trikes and
there's ones that just kind of sit there
and just act a lot versions we throw
around and they created the other
version the red carpet version Matt and
Josh the engineers decided they had
unfinished business and they created the
version that you see the premieres
that's the one that like nobody's
controlling it it's like robotic
be rolling around know something that
they drive it's a remote control but
it's a very clever piece of free rolling
tech it's amazing well you wouldn't do
that in the movie though
no is this why they were a little bit
but it's mostly done with a boo the
puppet version yeah yeah what is the
best reaction you had seen to bb-8 when
you're operating it it's people just
well actually when we did the first one
people didn't really know what they were
looking at the crew was just gone
certainly we've got their little funny
round ball thing but when laura dern
came on to the last Jedi she walk past
the the tent where we keep it and just
lost their mind bb-8 it's like yeah
laura dern from jurassic park so she was
quite excited I believe that surf all
Christian name yes yes yes what is and I
figure like you you would be a person
uniquely qualified to answer this
question what is the most for you the
most seminal puppet in pop culture Yoda
Yoda yeah that includes all the Sesame
Street Muppets and she just say Elmo not
for all of us although I like him a lot
I mean I grew up on the Muppets and
they're absolutely fantastic but for me
just looking at the performance that
Frank Oz put in and the Empire Strikes
Back when you stitch you to look about
the force it was just it was just this
thing acting you know and that's just
for me it was just so amazing
who was the dude it wasn't you I think
it was on set I was having a
conversation with the puppeteer in boss
who was telling me the story of like how
two Muppets start like had everything to
do England had everything to do with the
Muppets
because vitc the company that oh yeah
that well Luke Wright couldn't Luke Luke
Wright who ran one of those right EC Jim
Henson couldn't get that show
commissioned anywhere in the US so he
went I'll make it come over to England
so they went over there and built and
made I'll show ya so
piece of Americana what everybody thinks
of is like [ __ ] it's the Muppet Show man
it's as American as [ __ ] apple pie
and [ __ ] was made only because of and in
getting the entire times I shot every
episode that has made Elstree Studios
just obviously where they shot the
original Star Wars and that's sad do you
think I'm in well they were connected
anyway but is that that made it easy to
get Mark Hamill zoos across the street
what is what's been the weirdest moment
puppeteering on anything other than
laura dern well yeah
Elmo yeah elbow deep in her foot in a
bear or something that's gonna be the
name of your biography elbow deep in a
bear there was it was quite weird the
day we met Harrison Ford because we'd
been on the film for a while and it was
a like Star Wars but not still not quite
Star Wars cuz a stormtrooper something
new and that sort of stuff and then we
did all the stuff in the desert and then
we went and worked on the Millennium
Falcon set but it was with John and
Daisy so it's still quite like Star Wars
but not quite like Star Wars and then
Harrison came to work in his outfit with
his big hairy friend and I'm standing in
the in the corridor into the cockpit of
the Millennium Falcon with bb-8 and
wearing my fantastic green onesie and he
walked past me and just went who picked
the headlock and just thought what
thanks indeed and then we started
shooting the scene and I suddenly went
oh I'm in Star Wars and that was where
it really kind of landed but it was
really odd because this Harrison Ford
you know it's like oh no just when you
meet Harrison Ford that's not how you
want to be dressed not really no but
that was my gig and that was it you know
[ __ ] man
what do you go I'm just gobsmacked I
mean I'm thinking about Yoda again
because in my head just thinking about
like the history of movies and how
puppets have in some fashion or another
been part of that and you know my head
goes back to like Terminator like you
know Stan Winston putting that [ __ ] in
no armistice on his shoulders to be the
[ __ ] the t800 thinking about the joy
the the t-rex in Jurassic Park like a
decent chunk of that was all [ __ ]
puppets yeah on a bike
yeah well crystal I can't I can't [ __ ]
argue with Yoda man I mean the choice
yeah and it's the biggest swing of all
of them because Yoda could have gone
horribly wrong hmm and if he order
doesn't work that movie doesn't work and
they're like now if I could give it to
Frank you can I trust it like a
generation of children grew up watching
him stick his hand up things asses and
believe that they were real why wouldn't
it work now and were you there when they
did the last Jedi scenes with Frank no I
wasn't no I was there I was there no
idea I wasn't around for the for the
shooting but a whole bunch of guys that
we work with all the time were part of
his team so he's worked over there a
bunch right yeah aside from the Muppet
movies worked on like labyrinth which
I've met people on that crew yep
who were like oh we worked on labyrinth
I was like [ __ ] watch Horus guy is
nice yeah Little Shop of Horrors as well
it's crazy like every movie that I
remembered loving Oh with those
wonderful practical effects of they had
worked on over there I got to see Brian
actually work in action I mean we're not
brian particularly is not allowed to
talk about episode 9 by any stretch of
the imagination I can so while we were
there I saw Brian in action so I saw
Brian work I saw him work on force
awakens and I also saw him work here in
both occasions he worked with legacy
cast and the current cast famous [ __ ]
people
they all all treated him well from my
perspective because I'm like let's see
how they treat the puppet guy you know
because they're actors and they're
really interacting with each other and
then when they interact with prior
they're not interacting with him they
interact with bb-8 so it's almost like
they look through him and asked him and
like what are we gonna do Roly droid and
[ __ ] what is it like to be there and not
be there you have to be present in the
scene but not in the scene at all
because you can't be sort of looking at
Daisy well she's doing her thing so you
do you not look at her like the whole
time I'd be like uh-huh
you're making all the right choices have
to react with their Israel because I do
I lay down the voice so she has
something to react to so when she's out
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me that is how
you make a Star Wars movie like Brian
say beep beep boop yeah line beep beep
[ __ ] what was the last word boom oh
really yeah did they [ __ ] laugh when
you do it because they're professionals
but inside Daisy must be like oh my god
that's durable so then when you go see
the movie are you like oh [ __ ] they took
out my beep beep boop and put in that
fake synthetic beep beep but yeah I
didn't know what it sounded like until I
saw the film really I didn't know what
it sounds right so you made a whole
movie yeah thinking like I know what
he's gonna sound like and then the sound
mixers got your footage and they're like
beep beep boop and then they gave him
that [ __ ] that he does so I do alright
so then when you saw force awakens and
then every time you played bb-8 after
that do you still go beep beep boop or
do you try to mimic my that threw him in
the movies yeah can you do it
[Applause]
I just got a little wet listen to the
[ __ ] Peter Mayhew Chewie back in the
day man it's [ __ ] dope what has been
the weirdest moment outside of the
movies but because of the movies this
have you gotten to go to cons and stuff
like that yeah yeah I've just been under
quite a few issues lots of fun you know
you got to celebrate the big Star Wars
Celebration I was in Silicon Valley last
weekend and Colorado Springs next
weekend and they Dragon Con but that's a
lot of fun as well because people go did
you design it do the voice what do you
do I do is acting and they go oh isn't
it not CGI or how did you fit in that
ball which is always about figure Kenny
Baker in that [ __ ] I roll up real tight
and I [ __ ] roll around the desert
like Danny DeVito and [ __ ] [ __ ] man I
I've seen JJ work and described it many
times he's [ __ ] great at the job born
to do it you know you can't talk about
episode 9 but you can speak about
working with a month force awakens' tell
him what it's like working with JJ he's
amazing he's so much fun and he knows
what he wants and he makes his days and
he comes in and he gives you saying that
say that other thing he makes his day he
makes his day
that's incredibly important yeah
especially on a movie that [ __ ] big
cuz you don't get to say that on those
giant movies you rarely hear like a 200
million dollar movie hey we made our day
yeah so him making his days like he's
he's got that TV training where he knows
how to close and how to move and stuff
like that and that's all important when
you're spending like [ __ ] fifty
thousand dollars a minute and [ __ ] like
that to tell a story and he plays as
well which is great I mean he just he
plays music between takes and he just
kind of has a good laugh with everybody
and he's just great you can have a
conversation with them about an episode
about stop
that you really liked and then you'll be
chatting away and used to go off and
make the big film and then three days
later he comes back and says I'm what
about that thing where were you this and
you're like you're carrying this film on
your shoulders the start of the Star
Wars franchise and you've got Mission
Impossible on the go and whatever else
you're producing through bear robot and
you remember the silly conversation air
beneath three days ago yeah and that's a
big brain he's extraordinary yeah he's a
really good guy and stuff but I you know
I've been on those sets not twice and
I'm like always impressed watching ya
[ __ ] work incredibly wonderful with
everybody not like I treat the [ __ ]
you know I love the actors but like you
know [ __ ] off coffee person's like
treats everybody he like they're the
[ __ ] star of the show when when he's
talking in sub and directs with one of
these whole time he's on set like
whenever he's direct he's like okay
people because they've got [ __ ] a
sound system all over the joint and
because usually the sets are big it's
not like you're in a little room and
[ __ ] it's like massive so they got to
hear him in the far reaches so you'll
see him walk around with the mic
sometimes he like chit-chats he's always
given props and [ __ ] like he's my kind
of guy I love to watch him work I'm
trying to stay away from the new movie
although there's so many do it I know
well yeah I'm here let me I'll do it
this way all right did you see the
trailer for rise and skywalk I did yes
did you see bb-8 has a little friend I
did yes he came out at celebration do
they talked about it yeah yeah yeah okay
yeah I let's talk about deal they
brought him out it's cool do and he's
got and when he came out in celebration
did he come out by himself like like
yeah with no puppeteer or anything like
that so they built him like maybe the
same yeah they built that often but on
set I saw the puppeteer is quite letting
yourself yep
and of course we can't talk about other
than what they said at celebration which
is this is bb-8 buddy
yes he's online so it's like it's c-3po
had an r2d2 bb-8 now has d-a-d oh is
that a
when the Barney James do you yeah man
medalist when they brought in a new
little robot we were like [ __ ] I'm
getting out cuted I think there's room
for everything [ __ ] smart answer bad
well done do yeah adorable look real
[ __ ] cute what is what do you think
is the next leg of your workout do you
are you even allowed to say I don't know
sorry did you take part in Dark Crystal
wrong I didn't you don't get to go to
every party but I'm really looking
forward to it there are there's a lot of
your friends you get in this very room
did do that but what wait wait nothing
somebody's here that works on darker
maybe somebody here that worked on Dark
Crystal yet but I'm very much looking
forward to seeing it you you did you
work on Dark Crystal come on you got to
come over here man can you come over
here I just saw the [ __ ] billboard
what's his name Victor Garrett give it
up for him ladies and gentlemen what did
you do as one of puppeteers the Fox
seriously yeah they did announce Mike I
did a little puddling called hope
[ __ ] hey man now what was it like
they told me when I was over there
visiting the Star Wars pictures of some
of the cats were working on or had
worked on Dark Crystal they said they
liked you know some people were like oh
I guess they do it like CG but they
didn't they didn't [ __ ] the
old-school way that incident did it yep
with puppets they told us that they dug
out the [ __ ] floor of the soundstage
to build a real floor so that people
could puppeteer from underneath is that
true no that's not true
they do they just they just raisin sense
so that makes sense too
[Laughter]
dug into the earth and ship broken the
very Rock of England itself we got these
nineteen bulldozers out here what you
wanted to do with me he's like no they
just built up aren't you in movies was
it was it Teddy maybe who told us
somebody told us teddy
who's our exec on mo he's he's ours too
yes he's your exec he's the guy who's
responsible for getting it there man he
was champion but he was like yeah like
we did a bunch of tests with CG and then
we brought it back in and we all said
man this would look better with puppets
it's like it's gonna be a lot more
expensive with [ __ ] do little puppets
that's where it's supposed to be so make
it away it's supposed to be so the
puppet community must have been like
yeah cuz everyone was gonna [ __ ] work
there are a lot of [ __ ] characters in
the dark everybody's got kids go to
college yeah man it's one of those shows
you know movies that you know that world
of thraw was all puppets and and to go
back there I think I don't know you
could it would really feel like that if
you didn't have CG and half not so agree
yeah is the best man he he wanted that
from the beginning and supported that he
was there on set with us and came and
hung out and visited and stuff do you do
a puppet he did not he didn't I did not
see him do it but maybe in the workshop
the ways that you went out to England
and worked on yeah I was out there for
11 months why I didn't know before that
right online weed why now I this is no
disrespect to your abilities but like
I'm sure they got a bunch of puppeteers
in England why did they bring you over
there because you're like I'm the best
you know it's funny I went after them it
comes out I'll have to tell you that
story sometime because we have NDA's too
and I can't really tell believe me I
[ __ ] know I've also signed in Netflix
NDA of sort didn't honor it but I did
[ __ ] sign it because he's like the
Hooper of puppeteers man like if you
gotta jump that [ __ ] car you get the
best that's like the best publicist
you'll ever have thank you calling you
the looper of puppeteers everyone in the
70s would totally understand
right there were just three Americans
that went over that were lucky enough to
be a part of it cuz the right the first
one around was all Brits as well right
and and of course like Jim Henson and
Frank Oz and the core like Muppet guys
were there as well so I think it was
probably very similar you know just a
few Americans what is I've seen the
Billboard how many episodes is it ten
ten and each one like an hour long yeah
just about like a [ __ ] 10 hour Dark
Crystal movie it's 10 mini movies it's
it was not mazing working on it like
seeing the monitors on the day is just
it's epic it's for me is that most I
feel like I'm taking Brian you'll be
sitting over there no no we took a
timeout we [ __ ] blew bb8 a lot and so
take timeout talk dark crystals
puppeteering Appreciation Night you can
you can get into trouble now yeah but
believe me Brian's like yeah talk to him
what kit what's your favorite moment and
Dark Crystal and the 10 episodes what
should we be looking for it was a
highlight for you doing where they all
died right I would say you know I think
just the stuff that's immature I'm just
thinking like what I can talk about the
stuff in the trailer that's that's there
these epic battle scenes that you don't
really see with puppets cuz it's hard to
shoot with puppets like even even in
labyrinth them they have the big fight
scene and labyrinth it's it still comes
down to like I think I think that it
disappears wrong you know it disappears
I think you it feels like characters in
those scenes I think the battle scenes
don't feel like puppets knocking into
each other it really does I think I
don't know you judge for yourself but if
I achieve that
when's it starting if I'm seeing a
billboard I'm like a week and a half
it's like August 30th comes out we're
gonna have right on man give it up for
[ __ ] Scarface cross
[Applause]
you go back a long time with Star Wars
into your childhood and well not did you
have the action figures oh yeah
so you were puppeteering even as a young
kid yeah on this [ __ ] yeah
and then you actually grew up to real
puppeteer I got a report card and I was
about 10 that said that my obsession
with Star Wars would leave me nowhere
and I should concentrate on my academic
studies what what let me see I'm trying
to stay away from episode 9 were you
there blink if it's true this goes back
to force awakens were you there when
they shot the [ __ ] he sticks his
thumb out and does the lightest yes now
was that that's a combination of the
practical puppet version of EBA and then
a digital panel with a little digital
thump so did you know when you were
shooting the scene that he's gonna do a
little digital thumb they knew that at
that point I'm sure like that it's one
of my favorite bits in the entire
[ __ ] movie I mean it's a great gift
too it's always being used online what
is the weirdest compliment you've
received in connection to BBA like oh I
love your balls they roll across the
desert the biggest compliment is that
people can't tend to tell the difference
between the digital versions and the
puppet versions and everybody thought it
was digital when the trailer dropped and
so it's just nice because he is every
tool in the box and it's a massive team
effort so I mean I just happen to be
standing here now but there's there's so
many guys involved in it and what it's
just that little kids love it which is
the nice thing they just take it on face
value and that's a lesson really that's
a really big compliment I mean it's like
I'm glad we live in an era now of course
where people can use CG effects to
achieve the impossible and stuff but I
grew up in a rubber Air I grew up with
practical effects so I loved when they
said like all JJ's gonna do practical
effects on force
wiggins then we sir first started seeing
the trailers and stuff like it was a
whole heart whole hearted commitment and
stuff really nice to see you guys get to
work yeah you know right now we get to
see the the stuff that you do and can't
wait to see what you do in episode 9 do
you want to tell us anything that's
gonna happen and episode I'm concerned
she comes out the same day as cats
is it coming out the same day as cats oh
you guys are fine
give it up a bride everybody thank you
very much come on man you never [ __ ]
meet somebody that controls like one of
your favorite characters and a [ __ ]
instant addition to pop culture Canon
like everybody knows bb-8 that's nuts
[ __ ] bride touching legends and [ __ ]
all right that all we got for guests now
it's time for Q&A now it's not you now
it's time for a Q&A ladies and gentlemen
part of the show where we let you folks
ask three questions and then we give up
three prize packages which this week
will include I'll do these last so you
could do that right you'll get this the
three winners tonight will give this
beautiful print Batman Beyond done by
our great Nick Gonzales featuring me and
Mark signed by me and Mark and Nate man
that's part one of your prize package
part two is I brought bags of [ __ ] - I
do part two is you get a caviar hat
caviar is my favorite weed in the world
so you're gonna walk away with a caviar
hat third off you're gonna walk away
with one of these man it's a jar what's
it a jar for this is whatever you want
to put in it I choose weed so it's
little glass jar man by the good folks
at famous brands this one's a movie one
the other ones the giant saw Bob one and
no the other one's a Bluntman and
chronic ones so you're gonna log away of
those things and then last and certainly
not least is the biggest and best is
gonna walk away with two tickets to a 40
X screening of your choice man over at
la live is where we have our local 4dx
theater if you've not seen a movie in
the 40 X experience oh my god what are
you waiting for the chair [ __ ] moves
and [ __ ] if if it's if it rains in the
movie it rains on your face if a
motorcycle goes by it smells like burnt
rubber and [ __ ] like that once they get
around to porn this is gonna be an
incredible [ __ ] experience but it's
really credible right now and stuff like
that for DX cinema they the Deacon
always gets his tickets we thank the
good folks at 4dx and Brett Deacon as
well yeah but you got something cool
well also they're regal 40x is having a
best of summer 2019 sort of run so
between August 30th and September 4th
you can see Avengers endgame spider-man
far from home extended edition the lion
king toy story for Aladdin Hobson Shaw
and John wick 3 all in [ __ ] 4dx Wow
between those like 5 days so if you
think they're free tickets we'll get you
in to see free tickets we'll get you in
to see the biggest movies in summer if
you have like a kidney stone that you've
been trying to get worked out you go see
John wick and that much yeah wear a bra
that's all I'm gonna say hit me in the
face while I was watching a Civil War
all right so that's what we're that's
what we got that's what's at stake
ladies and gentlemen that's what we're
gonna be giving out we turn to JC the
proprietor of this here establishment
and we let JC pick our victims the
people that were speaking to Matt Peters
are you welcome Matt Peters ladies
gentlemen what can we do you for Matt
well thank you guys for calling me up
here I have a question for you this
evening
fire away all right so my question is
you guys are two of my favorite
podcasters they inspire me to do my own
I bought a couple of gifts for you here
from Chicago
those two mugs there
where where oh you were calling people
bugs over there you man actual bugs
it's my mug on mugs yeah Lux and that's
excellent adventure that's awesome mugs
we don't even have our own fogs you've
just given us an idea we're stealing I
got a mud guy if you're interested so my
question to you guys tonight is you know
since you're podcasters yourselves if
you could pick two fictional characters
to host a podcast together who would
they be and what would they talk about
wow what a great [ __ ] question number
one you're winning right away
who wants go first [ __ ] two fictional
characters though I got one of Ben Urich
and the [ __ ] other guy from Marvel's
know we'll go deeper than that who would
be a great listen who's a great it's
gotta be somebody's very chatty Doctor
Strange would be a great [ __ ] host of
a podcast never out of anything to say
we'll always have something to say and
let's be honest with you based on the
movies alone Tony Stark would be a
fascinating pot yes I can never run out
of material and [ __ ] those would be my
two they don't have to talk to each
other but I would like to see that as
well I kind of like who he's real though
Adam West yeah and if we're picking like
people have been past my father talked
about comic book characters man
I would like Sherlock Holmes and Columbo
one guy always talking about his wife
the other guy always looking for a
little morphine and sure doctor strange
like Mandrake the Magician or some [ __ ]
magic on magic magic magic yeah but but
Magic's not really a subject for a
podcast like magic you got to see like
on a podcast you're like I pulled a
dugout of my sleeve and people like well
I guess he did I can't see it you gotta
take him at his word and [ __ ] but just
like looking like strange knows a lot
about the multiverse god bless you and
just all the crap that
strange like to think about even if even
if you weren't talking about the ancient
one or [ __ ] the the eye of agamotto
or whatever he could just talk about
hand surgery which barely be interesting
in and of itself and [ __ ] or talk about
how like I was so good at it and by
pride it's gone I can't [ __ ] do it
you get paid folks out of that you'd
like this I feel bad for this hand
surgeon who's also a magician does that
covered let's do another example that
was marvel
let's do DC I'm going bigger than that
masters the universe he-man and Skeletor
on a podcast I wanted Skeletor and
Hordak for sure I would like KITT and
speed buggy to host the podcast it's
called talking cars cars talking cars
we're sports speed McQueen from [ __ ]
cars he can guest on the first episode
yes cars talking cars with cars coming
soon and Netflix oh I got one no Jericho
from the Titans and Silent Bob fastest
podcast you ever heard but every every
episode uploads it's like it's 74
minutes you know what could they not
talk about this week that is a great
question you win give it up for him lazy
[Applause]
[Music]
okay and the flowers are still standing
where to JC we have Kyle Wow everyone
welcome Kyle to the show
hey how you guys doing how are you so my
question is if you guys had to lose a
sense like touch taste smell hear or see
which one would you lose
gain superpower and why which sense
would I give up to gain a superpower
excellent [ __ ] question all right
what are the five senses seeing I want
the hearing I want that is talking one
of them I need the taste taste I got
none of that smell I would like that
touch yeah I want that I'd lose taste in
a [ __ ] heartbeat man because then I
meat and vegetables left and right he's
like what do I care it tastes the same
to lose taste do I get to pick my power
yeah I pick your power
hmm I'm giving up taste forever I should
get something good what do I want
you know this sounds [ __ ] corny but
like like peacekeeping powers to be able
to if I can walk up somebody hostile
just do this [ __ ] and they're like oh my
god you just reminded me of something I
did when I was a kid and I was so happy
and blah blah blah send them away that's
kind of useful and [ __ ] like that
because that means anybody attacking you
and [ __ ] you just be like oh you just
want to give like like orgasm powers
they don't need to come mark don't be
silly I mean but just to be able to be
like someone getting all hostile and
you're like oh like that's better yeah
you just would give you the [ __ ] Pope
of just like Dominus omus go about your
business you stop all wars anyway if you
do that and no but you got to be
realistic about it in order to use a
superpower you have to touch a person so
[ __ ] that's why you got a touch of
person you can't just be like Papa
dismiss them whatever I track your
thoughts is and that don't work I want
this [ __ ] power man that would make
people peaceful all right
so that'd be worth giving up sense of
taste for to be able to be like woohoo
and take the hostile away oh my [ __ ] I
could really fix the internet you got to
touch a lot of people though I know I'd
be something I'd be on a lot of [ __ ]
planes and [ __ ]
i I think I give up smell what yeah yeah
yeah why do you need to be smelling [ __ ]
most things you smell are not great and
otherwise you're just like oh I didn't
notice that and then you notice it and
it's never good
fair point man alright you're giving up
smell what are you gonna smell if you
give up smell I believe you give up
taste don't you aren't they connected
they're connected but not entirely well
you know if you have a cold you can
still kind of taste what you're eating
yeah part of me what you just [ __ ]
give out orgasms but that I feel like I
could run for like office with that [ __ ]
would you like somebody bug a bust a nut
yeah it's just by looking at him like
I'd really take the fight out of people
and [ __ ] you piece of [ __ ] you're my
favorite people become up to me yelling
[ __ ] knowing I'd make them come I hate
you thank you can I think I think I'll
go teleportation I think I do that one
because where are you going I said I'm
going it's like flight seems like you're
still [ __ ] commuting like there's
still time you've got to spend in the
air like there's still like I gotta know
where I'm going I got to relearn how to
[ __ ] get places in the air without
roads and if you're following the roads
that you just said you've too much
[ __ ] time but teleporting you like
camp at work because I still have to
work [ __ ] teleportation cuz I got
open a church if I could make people
[ __ ] come all the time what I love it
my things like I'd like to make people
less hostile and you're like I want to
get to work faster
that was a great question a great
question deserves a great prize package
give it up for Emily as a gentleman that
is you that is you that is you and these
40 X tickets are you Congrats
Louise say oh who is it Lewis Lewis join
us Louise give it up for Louise's
gentleman are we both sign in this I get
evening a huge fans thank you very much
for taking my question
my question was I'm having a freezing
maybe you guys oh my god don't freeze it
all man I'm sorry who gave me this hold
on who gave me this and that's I get to
keep this not for him for me [ __ ] you
mark never for me I just wanted to make
sure it was for him and that's a minute
and then hold on one more dot this is
too blunt man from stoned ninja stone
ninja who's responsible for this
that's you what is this self-published
it's a comic book about a ninja that
smokes a mystical strain of weed that
gives him superpowers why the [ __ ]
didn't I think of this you know all
those people are like guys he man
they're gonna sit around smoking weed I
should have thought of this but what a
good [ __ ] idea where can they get it
well currently if you're in LA there's a
handful of copies at Golden Apple and
they said to say hi oh we love the good
folks at Goldeneye and friends you can
go to stoned dot ninja and see all of
our cool merch we got t-shirts hats
rolling papers and I mean that [ __ ]
makes sense doesn't it
speaking his language as soon as I can
I'm we're based out of Memphis Tennessee
and I work with wonderful artist Greg
Cravens as soon as we can we're gonna
stop those rolling papers full of fun
stuff and then you can get them in all
your dispensaries - oh that's a good
idea Ryan I like comics but I love weed
give it up for him laser Jones we
created a thing sorry Louise sorry about
that back to you Louise now all of your
nerves should go away not quite but
we're thank you so much ride first off
thank you so much for being an
inspiration I'm here with my crew we
have a podcast your pin hold on we got
to do this properly short is the podcast
called the podcast is called - fanboys
and a filthy casual nice those are the
fanboys I am typically in the filthy
casual we talk lots of shirts that's we
have our 100th episode coming up so we
were inspired by all of your dialogue
about creating in the world full of
ill-will and destruction you guys are
championing creation and we are here we
want we want to make people happy so
thank you so much for all of your
contribution and all your support as
always thank you speaking of creating so
this is my class but this is my question
so congratulations on the Masters of the
Universe kick awesome stuff thank you
which Masters of the Universe character
do you relate most to and why um [ __ ]
this is very easy for me to answer at
this point Orko Orko I [ __ ] up all the
time and I'm always doing it with a good
intention like this will help and then I
put somebody in an airless bubble that
chokes them to death so yeah or it goes
though I mean look work go I think was
the way in for most kids in the cartoon
because we couldn't all be a man you
aspire to that but you can't even be the
person that has the high pitched voice
who they're always like ho
Orko so yeah we're Co identify with
part of me wants to say after tonight I
say evil in for you so sassy like
sometimes it's Tila cuz I feel pretty
and strong strong I think it's I think
it's Cringer I think it's a bit Cringer
because there's there's enough to be
afraid of in the world there's there's
enough to to sort of keep you in your
little tiny like fear shell but when the
time comes and when the dude hits you
would [ __ ] sword and says the words
you do what you got to get done but yeah
and it's also not there's nothing wrong
with being afraid you know like fear is
just another form of energy and all
Energy's good energy and if you could
channel it and if you can [ __ ] direct
it and you can sort of wield it then it
is as good as any other energy so yeah
there's there's and it's a thing that
it's it's talking to kids talking to
occasionally my kids about it's like hey
it's cool to be afraid we're all afraid
it's what you do when you're afraid that
matters because it's easy to do the [ __ ]
that you want to do when you're in brave
you know like a [ __ ] make you brave but
uh that from masters of the universe it
will be good and you episode 103 to mark
we have to cut this line now but like
it's just being afraid it's not the
worst thing in the world
so yeah Cringer I think and he has an
awesome [ __ ] but don't ride me I
don't to be ridden even when I get big
and strong not about that
you're still a top I started I'm not a
sloppy party Cringer I think let me see
if it wasn't for Co who I would like to
be is I don't go for the main guy and
[ __ ] like that because I I look terrible
in a loincloth
but man-at-arms wears a lot of clothes
that's my kind of guy and he's a [ __ ]
technically like just a killer like you
know he he's a badass like a mechanical
is a [ __ ] war expert and [ __ ] like
that you know in the original series he
was usually the guy delivering the
morale at the end but our version like
he's that but he's also man-at-arms he
lives up to his [ __ ] titles so he's a
god of badass so if I was to choose
anybody I would aspire to be it would be
that he's got [ __ ] wrist lasers for
heaven sakes
always cool yeah always very cool it's
all I got man there it is great question
it deserves a prize give it up for EM
ladies and gentlemen thank you well done
man was the podcast called again to
fanboys and a filthy casual there it is
well done that's how you mark it right
there what is this somebody put this up
here the rematch the decade Stairmaster
who's responsible for this anybody you
are you were come on up and talk about
this we'll get out of here what's your
name man Shawn everyone give it up for
Shawn yeah tell him what Stairmaster is
Shawn I did a piece for this years and
years ago tell them what Stairmaster is
Stairmaster
the Stairmaster project is we
essentially magnify the playground
pastime of staring contests to just
absurd proportions we've tell them what
the staring contest is you there's
cameras close-up on two competitors eyes
and you just stare at each other for as
long as possible without blinking and
when somebody blinks in the States
whistles blown and an arm is raised and
you move on to the next round in Japan
where the World Championships will be
held next year in 2020
there's also a little Ektron ik
so when you blink you get excellence
kidding me alright so for those of you
who like what they have staring contests
and you know here in the States
you lose when you blink but overseas
they kill you if you blink apparently
but you guys working on a flick
documentary yeah we would you called
Stairmaster
so not Stairmaster but stair mass
directly yeah and just finished that and
I was coming by to see if or just let
you know that we're taking that to the
next level what is the next level now
when you say finished it did you
finished shooting just finished a rough
cut of a documentary stir to making a
big deal about nothing and then
Stairmaster 2020 world domination
happens in Japan next to you and so are
you gonna shoot that for the current
Stairmaster documentaries a second no
that's there was a trilogy there the
original was in 2002 so all of that
footage has actually been collected and
read digitized so we could rillette it
maybe for like a smaller screen into a
longer series of 10 minute clips welcome
that is kind of what I'm doing right now
and that series will play out through
this next year whatever happens in 2020
but with money and making a big deal out
of nothing it could the absurd could
yeah I don't know we'll see how could
blow it up where can people support it
how do they support it where they find
it they don't yet but we're submitting
it to South by Southwest and other film
festivals this year and/or this month
actually [ __ ] a man right on it's
[ __ ] fun ideas good [ __ ]
well geez man that's all the show we got
for you and there was a lot of [ __ ]
shows a lot of stuff to think about and
stuff to rejoice and something to be
[ __ ] afraid about as well I'm sure
they'll work it out or whatnot but [ __ ]
there's a lot of content I'm out of
breath ladies and gentlemen do you have
a good time this evening I cannot thank
you enough for coming out and joining us
man but we got no show without the guys
standing next to me give it up for mr.
mark Bernardo and that is a fat man
beyond for this week sorry I'm Kevin
Smith hi I'm Mark Barnard tune in next
time same fad time same fat channel
SModcast calm or youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith by the power of Grayskull gonna
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]